una campaña de contrastes el presidente
Yair bolsonaro y el candidato
izquierdista Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
siguen en la búsqueda de nuevos adeptos
que los conduzcan a una victoria el 30
de octubre en la vuelta final de las
elecciones presidenciales las banderas
rojas ondean en algunas de las fachadas
de las favelas de Río de Janeiro y una
multitud rodea el camión en el que el
expresidente se dirige a su
simpatizantes
Lula vestido de blanco recuerda su
pasado sindicalista y se dirige México a
la multitud
una vez más los metalúrgicos arreglarán
este país
ganaremos estas elecciones ganaremos
estas elecciones para que nuestro país
vuelva a ser respetado
[Aplausos]
más alejado de las multitudes el actual
presidente Jair bolsonaro asistió una
misa en la Basílica del santuario
Nacional de Nuestra Señora de aparecida
en el estado de Sao Paulo el mayor
santuario católico del país antes de
esto participó en la inauguración de una
iglesia evangélica en el en Minas gerais
dos actos que buscan reiterar uno de sus
lemas de campaña Brasil encima de todo
Dios encima de todos además en las redes
sociales bolsonaro defendió su manejo
económico y su gestión como presidente
con las consecuencias de la pandemia y
una guerra que afecta a todo el mundo
Brasil va por buen camino En beneficio
de los pueblos gracias al historial de
reducciones de impuestos y a la
responsabilidad social del gobierno el
país respira mientras el mundo atraviesa
una histórica recesión y escasez
la recta final de la justa presidencial
se ha visto caracterizada por insultos
acusaciones cruzadas entre los dos
candidatos y por la ventaja del
expresidente una encuesta de ipec
publicada el lunes muestra que el
izquierdista amplió el margen frente al
actual presidente
yula se llevaría un 51% de los votos
frente al 42 de bolsonaro Sin embargo en
primera vuelta se predecían más de 10
puntos de diferencia que al final no se
cumplieron